malory how did you become a movie
producer so about three years ago I was
running a lot of horror events in New
England and from New England and I was
helping program and organize a horror
convention in Providence Rhode Island
and my boss Sultan Saeed alder Maki was
one of our sponsors and he had just
started dark dunes productions and
during the convention we met and really
really got along he was looking for
someone to run social media for the
company and run communications I could
do that we really just hit it off and he
hired me and at the end of the
convention so I started working my way
up in the company I started producing I
worked on kids versus monsters and as an
associate producer and I had a really
good time with that worked out really
really well and then we decided to go
forward with Yama song and now a song is
my first full producer role and it's
worked out so well we're going to keep
doing it so let me just go back so you
actually were part of producing the con
I mean that was it yeah idea well it
wasn't my idea but on it's called
Necronomicon providence and i got
brought in to run the volunteers and
just help with a lot of the
organizational problems that arise from
running a huge convention across
multiple buildings with lots of
thousands of people and I'd love to
organize and I just I love people and
very very social and it just sort of
worked out that I like to do it and my
boss saw those skills and sort of
decided to poach them for himself I know
before you were going to school to do
something with animals yes on during all
of this I was actually going to school
to become a zoologist I was working as a
veterinary technician and I was an
intern at a Wildlife Center in Maine and
I was doing all this in my spare time
because I'm just I love horror and I
love the genre and I love being involved
in events and just the scene of it and
so I just did it my spare time so you
were on the path to you know getting
your degree in in zoology and yes okay
so where did that then all play into
then being hired as communications
director well I also I'm just you know I
was very
at social media and I'm very very good
at organizing events and we had a lot of
things that dark dunes needed to
organize from the gecko and he you know
he wanted me to do it that's great so
did you then move to something or you
stayed there and did no I stated I
stayed in Providence for a little while
I'm one great thing about dark dunes is
that I you know and producing and
working in a lot of creative fields is
you can work from home so I never need
to be anywhere well whenever we do
events or shoots or specific things I
fly out and I'll be out there for be out
here in Los Angeles for weeks or months
at a time however needed but I always
went back interesting ok so that sort of
got your feet wet with producing right
because you'd always been an avid reader
absolutely do you credit maybe the New
England winters to being inside maybe
and just needing something well I've
always I've just always been a huge
reader I credit a lot of New England
stuff for my love of horror when you
grow up in a place that's so imbued with
history and a lot of dark history
especially in Massachusetts with a Salem
witch trials it's just sort of part of
the atmosphere that you grow up in and I
fell in love with it and also you know
Stephen King is all takes place in New
England HP Lovecraft takes place mostly
in New England so there definitely is an
undercurrent there and tapping into that
was really rewarding and fun and it just
sort of was part of my headspace growing
up I think I read somewhere on your
tumblr blog that you said your
grandparents used to always say like a
story for everything that you saw yes my
grandfather who most was sort of the one
who raised me everywhere we would go he
would make up some sort of story if we
saw an abandoned house in the woods he
would tell me that that's where Snow
White and the Seven Dwarves used to live
and he would always make up interesting
backstories for everything that I saw
out and about when I was a little kid so
I just sort of got this idea in my head
I sort of grew up in this era in this
moment headspace that everything had a
story and that everywhere I went there
was something interesting and that I've
really carried with me into
filmmaking wow that's interesting so
even even as like as young as like seven
or eight you would just always be coming
up with little things for a piece of
paper that you see on the yep ground
stories for everything and he wouldn't
he would tell me a story before bed
every night and I would I've been
writing since since I can remember and
you know it just stories were sort of
the currency of my life do you remember
the first story that you wrote and how
old you were yes I do it was a story I
was probably seven it was a story about
a little dog that was trying to catch
fish with its tail I remember writing
this and my grandfather loved it and I
just love that feeling of putting what
was in my all these stories that had
been swirling around in my brain she's
sort of putting them on paper and
bringing them to other people I loved it
and I've been doing it ever since Wow so
it sounds like your grandparents really
encouraged you instead of like maybe
trying to squash and say oh no little
girls shouldn't be writing oh no my
grandparents are very very supportive my
grandmother is not with us anymore but
my grandfather has always been super
super supportive of lots and lots of
reading lots and lots of writing
especially now in most of my life I've
been very much involved in horror and
sort of the weirder elements of
storytelling and he was always very very
encouraging about that which I'm very
fortunate what was the first movie he
took you to see Balto the Disney I don't
know if it's a Disney animated movie but
it was an animated film about this husky
sled dog team and I've always loved
animals
so I remember said very clearly I don't
remember what year it came out but that
was the first movie I ever saw in
theaters anyway so then what was the
first inkling that you said instead of
writing I'd like to make film so it
seems like you're very interested in
literature especially fiction horror
fiction well I I do I do write and I'm
working on a book right now and I am
that is another part of what I do but
I've always films have always been a
super important part of my life and just
visual storytelling is always
really appealed to me so when I got
offered this job at dark dunes
productions being able to start taking
some of the stories that I've always
been in my head and have been put on
paper and being able to transfer them
onto the screen and onto film was I got
really really enthusiastic about it and
I've been in love with it ever since
Mallory was this the first time you'd
worked with puppets I know with Yama
song there's they're all animated well
they're not animated they're all there
live-action puppets it is actually not
the first time we've worked with puppets
or the last feature that we did kids
versus monsters some of our monsters
were puppets and we had so much fun with
them and we've just absolutely endured
getting into the world of puppet
filmmaking Wow okay so it's so animation
be where you're you're drawing it or
there's a cartoonist so with this it's
it's like these live-action things that
you're having thoughts like a marionette
yes well what it's called American
tabletop and it's an American version of
a Japanese form of puppetry called
Bunraku and instead of and in Japan it
would be all black puppeteers in like a
complete black suit on a black
background doing the puppets and they're
called rod puppets they're about this
big and they have rods stuck into their
joints
sometimes there's mouth and hand
movements but it's mostly rod puppetry
but the way that we do it is that we
have all the puppets on a green screen
with people in complete green suits and
we digitally remove the puppeteers and
put digital backgrounds or real
backgrounds in behind the puppets Wow
okay so let's take a 10-minute scene
with the puppets how long would that
actually take to film it could take all
day it could take a couple of days
there's I mean it's just like a I mean
we're shooting it live-action so it's
sort of like working just on a regular
film set you have to set everything up
you have to light everything you have to
do it several different times and what
the way that we do it is that we record
the voices first of all the actors and
then the puppeteers actually puppeteer
to the voices and they do it a little
bit we speed the voices up just a little
bit so it ends up looking natural Wow
okay so the script the the the audio is
pretty much already done aside from any
type of music or
we work we we we do our best and we at
least with llamo song we were able to
record all the voices for all our voice
talent first that way our puppeteers can
actually puppeteer perfectly to the you
know up to all the different inflections
and the voices so then I would imagine
that the script is locked at that point
in terms of dialogue and everything
definitely okay I mean we can I mean we
can change the scenes around a little
bit but dialogue wise were locked in
you're locked in okay and so then the
puppeteer is what's their process for
listening to the dialogue so they really
get a feel I mean we play it in the
onset we have it blasting out of
speakers so they they're hearing it
they've read the script they're familiar
what's going on and they're listening
over and over again to to the lines so
they I mean by the end of it they they
know everything perfectly once you get
on set how much time do the puppeteers
have actually getting a feel for the
different animal that they're working on
because they were all animals in the
there they're sort of humanoid animals
but they're they'll they'll take they'll
take time to you know get a feel for the
puppet how it moves they'll do a bunch
of test scenes you know just see how
it's going to work because fitting when
a puppet to this big some of I mean some
of our puppets take five people to
puppeteer so it's it's a very
interesting choreographed movement to
get all five people because one person
might be just doing one and two arms and
one person be doing two legs one person
won't doing the head so there's
definitely some test runs before we
start shooting just to get it all moving
correctly when you were little did you
go to puppet shows I actually had my own
marionette theater that my grandfather
built me I've always really loved
puppets and I would put on little shows
with the marionettes so it's always
there's something about puppet
filmmaking and being able to have total
control and being able to move these
these either humanoids or animals and I
mean this obviously more things that you
can do with puppets then you can do with
real humans and there's an exaggeration
and a hyperbole of emotion and movement
that you get from puppets that is
physically impossible from humans and
it's it's
learned animation in the way that you
can get these big big movements and
these big these big emotions and these
big ideas with puppets that and it's
just so fun and so rewarding and it's a
very interesting way of telling a story
so with each of the puppeteers let's
suppose there's going to be two
puppeteers working on one puppet how
much backstory do they go into for that
one character to know kind of even its
body language and let's suppose it's a
more demure the animal figure versus a
more extroverted one oh I think the pup
I mean the puppeteers are they're just
like actors and they have they all have
their own method of getting into the
character and understanding the
character and after they've read the
script I mean everyone's different but
they definitely sort of have an idea of
who the character is what their
motivations are what they love what they
want in this scene it's just it's like
being dealing with a teeny tiny little
actor so you had a your own little
marionette theatre when you were a child
which I'm so envious of because I wanted
that when I was a kid and I could never
find a real puppet show place to go to
but I'd see it on TV or whatever that's
I'm getting diverted but what were some
things that you were surprised at
working with puppets even though you'd
really been in the driver's seat as a
child but then once you got into the
filming process it surprised you I think
I got surprised by how much fun it still
was I mean when you're when you're on
set and you've been on set for 12 hours
and everything it's all the normal
grueling schedule of a regular film set
but there's levity and a joy that comes
from working with puppets that kind of
keeps it a steady level even throughout
all the stress and the long hours and
there's because essentially what you're
doing is a professional form of playing
and it's still so much fun even when
you're fresh you know you've just all
stressed out and you only have so much
time and you have to make your day
you're still working with these fun
beautiful toys and it was amazing to to
be able to work with that
now the writer how much did she give
input on like what the puppets were
wearing or if I know if they're all
animals they have like fur and things
like that but actually our writer
ekaterina cydia she didn't have any
input on the aesthetic of the film in
any way but our costumer Ayumi more she
she's the one who designed all of what
the puppets were wearing and she did
such an incredible job there i if you
get to see some of the pictures of the
puppets the detail and the intricacy in
all of the costumes is astounding in
terms of reviewing what the the animal
would look like how many meetings that
you have over well let's change the fur
here let's maybe lighten it up there we
didn't have any meetings we actually our
director sam koji hail Yama song is his
vision and we one of the reasons why we
wanted to do Yama song and we chose him
is because we had complete and absolute
faith in his in his direction and his
vision and what he wanted and everything
that came out of his mind
visually he did all these amazing
sketches of all the characters and for
some of the characters because Yama song
was actually it's there was a short
first so some of the main characters
Nani and shogen abigail breslin
and nathan fillion s character were in
the shorts we had them already and we
had an idea of what they were going to
look like their size how what they were
gonna be dressed as and we loved it so
much that we let Sam really just do
whatever he wanted and we just trusted
him and we're so happy that we did so my
sense is that you didn't have any of the
hands-on and making the puppets right
you were just there no we were we had a
really amazing puppet fabrication team
and they were all headed out by Sam Sam
really directed the aesthetic of every
character every scene of every set and
we just loved everything that he did so
can you take us through the beginning
stages of putting the movie together you
know once you were sort of presented
with the idea and you knew that you were
going to Torrent turn excuse me this
short short film into the feature what
was your first step so after we met with
Sam we decided that we wanted to do this
we loved the idea we loved the short the
first step was going to fabrication we
needed to build all these puppets we
need to start building us that we
to rent a space to start creating all of
them and while that was all going on our
writer ekaterina was working with Sam
and I was working with both of them to
edit and create this script and get it
all together so it sort of was this big
big bang explosion of we knew what the
characters were we knew what they wanted
them to look like so we were creating
them at the same time we were creating
the story and it was a very highly
powered super creative time it was a lot
of fun okay and so then once that whole
part of working together the three of
you then when did you actually go to
production it took about six months to
get to get all that done and we shot
Yama song and sort of an interesting way
we didn't shoot it all at once we shot
it for one week a month over the course
of many months because the thing with
the puppets is that they're unlike
humans they can't have too much wear and
tear on them so we would do one week of
shooting and then they would go back and
get repaired shored up and then the next
month we would do another week and like
we all while that was going on we were
building new sets and it was sort of a
very on it wasn't just let's shoot it in
a month and then when then we're done it
was an ongoing process and where was all
the filming and the voice work done we
did everything here we shot it in
Glendale and we recorded most of the
voices in Los Angeles the only voice
that we shot in New York was Whoopi
Goldberg because she she does the view
and she stays in New York and she
doesn't travel so we um we recorded it
at a studio there but everyone everybody
else was in Los Angeles what are some of
the things that have changed in your
life since making the film a lot of
things have changed ever since Yama song
came out Yama song really was the next
step for filmmaking with us working with
big you know big-name talent a bigger
production we got you know amazing
publicists we every everything with Yama
song sort of took us to the next level
and we're sort of springboarding off of
that now it was Yama song was we really
sort of concentrated everything that we
had and all these lessons that we had
learned on other features we had done
and made this big leap in it and we
landed it and when does the Alma song
come out
we have no release date for Yama song
yet we don't have a distributor for it
we're still we're still creating it
we're in post-production right now or
we're putting all the fee effects
together and scoring and we're putting
all the finishing touches on it so we
don't have a distribution date yet
Mallory who was the first big-name actor
that signed on to Yama song we actually
got Malcom McDowel first because he had
worked with us on kids versus monsters
so he wanted to do another dark Tunes
production we were really happy to cast
him as Lord Gere his voice was perfect
for it and then once you found out that
he was attached it was probably very
easy then to get other names as well
well with the process after Malcolm
signed on is that we got our two
executive producers Toby froude and
Heather Henson and once we had their
names attached to the project that's
when we started getting you know will be
we Goldberg and Nathan and that's when
all the other talents sort of fell into
place after that it was a course of a
few months to cast everybody and so once
you had him attached then did you go and
actively seek out these two producers or
you shopped it around and we
specifically looked for them oh you did
because I mean proud and Henson those
are the two biggest names and puppets
sure so we definitely we wanted them
specifically any tips to other
filmmakers excuse me
any tips to other producers on when you
know certain people you want attached
the approach because sometimes I know
it's a gentle approach other times it's
good to be aggressive I think there's
like a balance there definitely is a
balance and I think the thing that at
least worked for us was just our
enthusiasm for the project Yama song is
such a unique and completely different
than anything else that's out there
right now and we love it so much and we
were so authentically excited about it
so we were we weren't super aggressive
but we were just overjoyed with what we
had and that really attracted a lot of
people to it right so it sounds like
just the authenticity this teach you
what you love uh-huh
and show through definitely were there
times when you were presenting it to
these two producers that you were like
if this doesn't happen like you you felt
that like I need this to happen but you
knew you had to kind of quell yeah we
keep we keep all that uh-huh right what
do you do when because I know this is an
overwhelming city and I know you just
moved here when when you feel anything
like okay I need to take a break for a
second because I'm getting to you know
even if it's something that you totally
love we all get very excited about what
we want to do and we want it to happen
so badly what do you do to calm yourself
down and take your self out of that
mindset for just a little bit and I
agreed a lot oh really what do you read
I read everything I read probably 100 to
200 books a year and I read a lot and I
read in all genres horror is definitely
my absolute favorite genre to read but I
read a lot of literary fiction sci-fi
fantasy romance westerns nonfiction
science books everything a lot of
graphic novels as well Wow and then
these are not books on tape that you're
listening I do also listen to books on
tape
okay so audible membership and things
like that I have a script membership at
EIU I listen to i'm as many isn't it
many stories as i can get into my brain
at once i I do Wow you know it's such a
lost art these days it's actually
picking up a book and and reading it so
wouldn't you make time for it when
you're writing a subway or where is it
well I I cheat a little bit I'm an
insomniac
so I spend a lot of time than I probably
should spend sleeping reading but I just
I really feel like if you love something
and you want something to do you want
time to do something you make time for
it
you make time for everything everyone
has the same hours of the day so I just
make reading a priority for me and for
me picking up a book is like turning on
the TV for somebody or picking up a
glass of wine or someone baking it's
it's my brain off relax
refuel and it also recharges me a lot
creatively so I just make sure to at
least make an hour a day for it what are
the top five books that someone injured
genre or that's interested in horror my
top five horror books that someone
should read right now
a head full of ghosts by Paul Tremblay
haunting of Hill House by Shirley
Jackson broken monsters by Lauren
kiss horns by Joe Hill and the last
werewolf by Glen Duncan I think you
talked about that on your blog or maybe
some I talk about I probably talked
about all of my blog I'm I'm very very
vocal on my social media and in my life
about the books that I love I'm very
much via fountain not a drain and I love
to talk about the things that I love and
I really love books oh I like that thing
that's great yeah that's good so when
you do find a book that you love do you
find that you devour it in one sitting
I can definitely if I really loved
something I just go and I will read it
and I'll just spend all night reading it
Malorie I know you're new to the LA area
and I saw that you had something on your
blog about like networking and you put
networking is like kissing can you
explain I think networking is just like
kissing because it's something that
everybody else seems to know how to do
but you they can't explain it to you how
to do it something that you just have to
do by doing but it's also very very
important and unlike kissing networking
is incredibly important for the creative
person to learn how to do and know how
to do and be able to balance being able
to promote yourself but also being
polite and being able to work with other
people and for some people that's a hard
line to walk I think on your blog you'd
said something about you know business
cards and it's better to not just maybe
present it right away but first connect
with the person oh definitely I really
think that the only time it's
appropriate to give somebody a business
card give something a watch link to a
short film you've done you're any sort
of business handover you have to have a
connection with that person and it's
important to my rule with networking and
with most interactions with people that
you don't know especially business stuff
is be interested and also interesting
it's a 50-50 and there's if you're
talking to someone and you're really
excited about your project you also have
to remember that they're here for a
reason and they want to tell you about
their project so you want to be talking
as much as you are listening and after
you've had a really good connection with
someone you've talked about what you
want to do then
I think is the time to say hey I've
really enjoyed talking to you here's my
business card please email me here's a
Vimeo link to a short I've done if you
want to see it that way it doesn't feel
intrusive and that way someone remembers
you a lot of I'm sure everybody's had
this experience after a networking event
you have all these business cards and
you don't remember who gave them to you
because there was no connection to go
along with them but if you've talked to
somebody and you if they've made some
sort of impression on you then you can
remember oh this is the person that I
had that great conversation about you
know lighting with and and that is a
basis to form a business relationship on
you have to create some sort of
foundation first what about a serial
connector but then they don't follow up
I see a lot of that sometimes and what's
your answer for that for someone who
seems to want to connect you follow up
with them and then you don't hear
anything back or you do and it's like a
few weeks later and it's not clear on it
with people like that I just don't even
worry about it I don't have time for
people like that you just move on just
move on I mean if it's if it's a
connection that you really really want
you might want to pursue it a little bit
but generally if I really am firmly of
the camp that if you are getting some
sort of strange feeling from somebody
and you aren't don't have a strong
connection with them it's probably not
going to work and that that uneasiness
is probably going to continue throughout
the business relationship that you try
to create with them you also say don't
drink too much and networking events
which is funny because you want to be
relaxed but like that's the other thing
that you need to balance is that you you
want to be participating with everybody
you want to have fun you you know but
you also need to keep your head and
people are watching that stuff and
especially in the creative world there's
a lot of people that over indulge and I
know people that have rules of that oh I
don't want to work with anyone who
drinks too much so you again balance
yeah not support what is making yamas on
taught you about filmmaking making yama
song has taught me that you need to be
you need to do what you love and you
need to be authentic
and ever a lot of people get into this
industry because they want to be famous
or they want to make money but with the
law making a film it's like being it's
like having a child you're with it for a
long time especially if you're a
producer and you're with it from its
inception to selling it and promoting it
and trying to get it out into the world
and if you don't love a project and you
don't feel genuine enthusiasm for it a
few months in its gonna feel like a drag
it's gonna feel like a bad marriage so
with the AMA song we took a lot of risks
because it is such a unique and
different project than a lot of people
have seen and a lot of people ever
people don't really know where to put
yama song they don't know if it's an
animated film or not and it's something
you know people haven't made a puppet
film in America since Team America 11
years ago so it is something that but we
felt so strongly about it and we loved
it so much and that enthusiasm and that
love for it has carried us through all
of the trials and tribulations of making
a movie has anything changed for you
like an initial reason and then a new
reason has evolved out of it which was
just as positive as your initial reason
for getting into it I'm not sure I okay
like you know a lot of people I think do
come to LA to be famous or for whatever
reason and then I think maybe some of
that wears off and then they really love
what they're doing as like they don't
really need too much gratification from
other people has there been something
other than maybe being famous or
whatever that maybe you initially
started because you loved writing but
now with puppets I mean I know you had
the marionette theater but this like a
new turn has come that really like sent
a spark well part of filmmaking that I
was that was very sort of surprised at
and I loved it is the community aspect
of it I mean a film set is like a
military camp you know everyone has
their own place and there's an energy to
that many people being focused on one
particular thing at the same time that
is absolutely electric and it is so fun
and I love it so much and it's something
that I wanna
definitely keep being involved in and
keep working with for years to come I
was not expecting it right especially if
you love reading and it's such a
solitary thing definitely and so how has
that been I don't know if you're more
introverted or I am definitely a big
extrovert usually okay so I definitely
do love to read but being working in
film and the collaborative aspect of
film was something that I kind of always
knew in the back of my head and it
wasn't until I actually started making
films with dark dunes and being on set
and in creating that I just it just gave
an eyes to me and I love it so much do
you remember the first film set you ever
saw even from afar even if you weren't
part of the production the first one I
ever saw was the first one that was on
actually it was kids vs. monsters
oh wait that's not true the first film
set I ever saw was for Harbinger down
which was our second film and we were on
the set but it wasn't shoot they weren't
shooting at the time and there's a lot
of magic to a created world and with
Harbinger down it was a movie that takes
place on a boat in the Arctic but they
had created the set in a warehouse in
Los Angeles so stepping out of the heat
and into this warehouse and then all of
a sudden you're on this boat and you're
in this underground or you know under
under the ship and this this hull is
there and there's all these these
hatches and doors and stepping into that
magic and that transformative aspect of
filmmaking was just amazing
how is being part of making a con
similar to making a movie well there's a
the differences between running a
convention and writing a film set aren't
aren't too big actually because you're
organizing a massive amount of people
everybody is doing a different thing and
it's all it needs to happen over the
course of a few days so there's a
massive amount of prep for both of them
and then all of a sudden it all happens
within for a film you know it can be a
week to several months and for a
convention it can be a day to a week or
maybe a couple of weeks but it's this
frenzy of making sure that everybody is
doing the thing that they need to be
doing at the same time
and this I mean the the organizational
aspect is incredibly similar for me it's
both a lot of fun I love to organize but
they're that level of high intensity
stress is very very simpler okay what
are some things that really help you
stay organized even if you're someone
that loves organization because I really
believe there's some people that they
thrive on organization and then some
that that's kind of not their strong
point but even for someone that loves it
and who's detail-oriented what helps you
my planner I don't I will be buried with
my day planner I love it it is it keeps
me organized to the day to the hour to
the to the week to the month it's filled
with post-its it keeps for me I am a you
iPhones and iPads and digital technology
is wonderful but I'm the sort of person
that likes to be able to see everything
at once whenever I need it so being able
to literally unfold my week and have a
very concrete tactile representation of
what I'm going to be doing is
indispensable to me so then don't have
it all on your device that sounds like
yeah I mean I have all of my stuff on my
iPhone and I very frequently work for my
phone but being able to sort of unfold
it and just have it in my hands makes it
feel quite literally more manageable did
you learn that the hard way because I
just recently broke my screen on my
phone and I was without it for several
days and it taught me a lesson
so did was that something I've always
I've always been a paper person it's
always helped me and now working as a
producer and doing all these other
things working in the creative world
there's a lot of strange hours and
meetings there's all sorts of things
that are different than your normal
nine-to-five so being able to have a
tangible place to put all of that and
see it is I need it when you wake up in
the morning what's the first thing that
you do check my email I know I shouldn't
but it's the finale
easily the first thing I do I check all
my different email addresses and then
once you do do you almost feel like it
because it definitely guides you for the
day right you know what's the most
urgent thing to do probably from that
point yes and checking my email being
able to see where
things that make sure there were no
emergencies nothing happened overnight
being it sets the tone for my day and
makes me feel like I have a little bit
of control over what's going to happen
and what I need to do I get that I
definitely get that helps a lot